So at the last company I was working at,
I was helping set up their
user testing program.
And one of the products
that they were testing for
was a desktop control software.
So it helps you use your desktop.
And we realized very early on,
that obviously we're not going to be
in the room when our user
starts to use the software.
We're not going to be able
to give them instructions.
to tell them how to use it.
So we also had to use some machine
learning algorithms to help
detect what the user intended to do and
have the software respond appropriately.
And we realized that
the machine learning algorithms
were very finely tuned at first to us.
We would say,
we would do a certain thing and
it would get it every single time.
And we would give it
to somebody else and
they would inevitably do
something different and
it wouldn't work at all.
So, what we ended up doing is creating
a tutorial video, and this was,
our idea was that this is a prototype of
the actual video that would ship with
the product to explain to a customer or
a user how to use it.
And we ended up user
testing those in parallel.
So when you bring a user in our user
testing lab, we would sit them down,
say we were going to show them a video.
We are going to then give you
a set of tasks with a software and
see how well you do.
And then all the, we're not testing you,
we're testing the software, all of that.
And the we would sit them down and
we would shut up.
The tester would shut up,
roll a video, and
be very careful not to actually
put their hands out or show them,
how to use the software, and
then we would test them.
And so by optimizing those in parallel,
we ended up getting much,
much better performance, and
a much better prediction of the eventual
user's performance, than we would've
if we had demonstrated how to do these.
Because we know how to trigger
the machine learning algorithms.
>> Right, perfect.
Thank you.